hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast the role of vaccination for
the treatment and prevention of breast
and ovarian cancers he is presented by
Keith Knutson PhD a professor of
immunology at the Mayo Clinic I am Judy
O'Rourke of laberd's and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots lab
roots is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
anytime you want during the presentation
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and type your questions into the
drop-down box it appears on the screen
our speaker will respond to your
questions via email if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits please
join me in welcoming dr. Knudsen I will
now turn the presentation over to him
thank you Judy and thank you everybody
for your participation in in this
presentation our laboratory has been
working on developing vaccine approaches
and other immune therapy approaches for
the treatment and prevention of cancers
for a couple of decades now our primary
focus is on the development of vaccines
for breast and ovarian cancers which I'm
going to spend the vast majority of my
time on today we have some conflicts of
interest we over the course of our
discoveries and implementation into the
clinic we license technologies to small
companies enabling them to carry them
through hopefully one day into clinical
use in the marketplace so breast and
ovarian cancers represent
a worldwide problem healthcare burden
across the world there are a couple of
million cases every year of both of the
cancers combined but notably there's
over 650,000 deaths in the u.s. we have
240,000 cases of breast in 22,000 cases
of ovarian cancer every year for a
combined total of about fifty four
thousand deaths the costs are tremendous
if you use the Swedish model of
estimating costs or from the American
Cancer Society the estimates for breast
cancer alone are on the order of about
one hundred and eighty billion dollars
now that represents about one percent of
our gross domestic product and is just a
few percentage points less than we spend
on our military budget so you can see
that it's a huge health care burden to
deal with these cancers and efforts are
being made in our laboratory and other
laboratories across the u.s. enabling
the development of new approaches for
the treatment and prevention our focus
has been on the identification of
strategies to improve the ability of the
immune system which is the body's drug
making machinery to combat cancer so one
of the unique features of the adaptive
immune system is that consists of
specialized cells called t-cells or
b-cells these are very unique in that
each one has unique proteins that help
them recognize certain abnormal proteins
in the body such as cancer proteins or
proteins derived from microbes such as
bacteria or viruses in addition there
are different flavors of the immune
response as we've learned over the past
a couple of decades in which we can use
information that we can use to design
effective vaccines for cancer so for
example there are what we call th17 th1
th2
types of t-cells that deal with
different kinds of microorganisms and
with different types of cancer and our
strategies are aimed at generating
specific flavors of the immune response
so we've known now for several years
actually that the immune system
naturally responds to cancer but breast
and ovarian as well as other cancers and
this is shown here in this particular
slide from a colleague that published in
New England Journal of Medicine back in
2003 that showed in this instrumental
landmark paper that if you have T cells
in your tumor which we designate in
their tumor old T cells you have much
better outcome in ovarian cancer and the
same goes for breast cancer as well our
group has shown that the this immune
response that is associated with either
ovarian cancer breast cancer is antigen
specific so it recognizes specific
abnormal proteins on these tumor cells
enabling the immune system to generate
immunity with the hope that it can
combat it so the question comes up is
why if your immune system recognizes
your cancer do the cancers grow out well
that's always been a fascinating
question for us to try to answer and
through the years we have identified a
number of strategies that cancers use to
evade the immune response and they do so
through activating immune suppression
your immune system is very sophisticated
so in addition to the T cells and B
cells it has a lot of mechanisms in it
that prevent it from overacting in some
cases those mechanisms break down and as
a result autoimmunity such as rheumatoid
arthritis or multiple sclerosis etc
develop in an individual as a result of
the breakdown of these immune
suppression or regulatory mechanisms
well it turns out that cancer actually
uses these mechanisms to hide itself
from the immune system so
answers despite the fact that they're
recognized by the immune system and
should be attacked by the immune system
use a wide variety of strategies to
prevent and I'm just showing a couple of
examples here for example regulatory T
cells or T regs which are a specialized
subset which suppress the immune
response they get into high tumors and
very high numbers you can see that in
that picture on the bottom right hand
side where you have these regulatory T
cells in the tumor they're blocking the
immune system there's other kinds of
cells that also block the immune system
so when we think about how to enable the
immune system to combat cancer we need
to think about mechanisms that overcome
this immune suppression in the cancer
micro environment and one way that we
can do that is we can develop immune
therapies that boost the immune system
to very high levels and that we'll get
many many T cells and many many B cells
into the tumor microenvironment
sometimes that doesn't always work but
that is the goal so we have a number of
different approaches that you may come
across in the reading of literature or
watching shows on TV that tell you about
any embraced approaches for the
treatment and prevention of cancer so
one of them is cancer vaccines and these
are very much like regular vaccines and
I'll get more into that but there's also
what we call antibodies and these are
produced by b-cells we can make these
these now in laboratories and we can
give you high doses of antibodies that
will combat the cancer we can also grow
your T cells outside of the your body
and give them back in very high numbers
that's called adoptive t-cell therapies
and we also have a number of ways now to
reverse that immune suppression in the
tumor micro-environment and that allows
for your immune system to really take
off and come and combat the cancer this
has been very effective approach in
recent years and has been approved in a
number of different cancers such as
melanoma and lung cancer one great
example is malignant melanoma that was
metastatic to the brain and President
Jimmy Carter he was treated with an
immune checkpoint blockade strategy that
essentially reversed the suppression on
his immune system and allowed his immune
system to combat the cancer as a result
the immune system completely wiped out
the cancer in his brain and he's going
out on two more years of living so let's
get back to cancer vaccines now there
are a number of different choices for
how we develop cancer vaccines we call
these neo antigens so these are new
antigens to the immune system their
printings there's a couple of different
ways to think about this for example
there are what we call microbial neo
antigens so for example if we knew that
breast cancer ovarian cancer was caused
by a bacterial virus we could just make
a vaccine based on that virus or that
bacteria a great example is human
papillomavirus vaccine which prevents
cervical cancer so what that vaccine
does is it actually targets the virus
that causes cervical cancer
the unfortunate thing is that breast and
ovarian cancers don't or are not caused
to the best of our knowledge by either
bacteria or viruses so we need to think
of other other approaches there are in
the green box shown here a number of
other unique proteins that are that
result I'm not going to go into all of
these but they result from mutations
that occur in your chromosomes and the
problem with targeting these specific
mutations in the green box here is that
they're all very unique to people and so
we can't come up with an off-the-shelf
vaccine that we can give to people that
would enable them to boost their immune
responses against their cancer so we've
come up with a different strategy and
that's the bottom bullet point there is
to target self antigens and what we call
sub dominant proteins or sub dominant
neo antigen
these are normal self proteins that are
in the body but the tumor cells display
them inappropriately or aberrantly so
they're very unique to the tumor
microenvironment and it turns out that
your immune system can recognize those
so if we can harness the power of the
immune system to recognize these sub
dominant neo antigens or proteins on
tumor cells that would enable us to
generate potentially effective vaccines
now for scientists out there one way to
think about this is in this cartoon here
in a normal cell you have normal
proteins shown in blue on the left hand
side being displayed at the cell surface
of the normal cell that's under normal
conditions a tumor cell may express a
whole bunch of these different proteins
much higher levels than would occur in
normal healthy cells and as a result of
that much higher expression you get more
of these red proteins on the cell
surface your immune system can recognize
that and if we can identify those which
is what we do in our laboratory we can
actually develop vaccines that stimulate
the immune system that can target those
red proteins on the top of tumor cells
here's a great example we have tumor
cells here and this is a complex
experiment and I'm not going to go into
all of it but we have a complex mixture
of cells T cells and tumor cells that
are shown in the upper two right panels
there where you can see that the T cells
which are showing in the elevated lines
on the graph as recognizing and killing
that we call that lysis the tumor cells
but if you take an ordinary heart cell
which is in the two panels just beneath
those you can see now that we can
develop strategies that specifically
could recognize tumor cells but not
normal healthy cells in the body we can
formulate those into vaccines that
enables the body to develop immunity
against the cancer we started this
actually
several years ago back in the 1990s and
we use some very old programs to
identify what these proteins were and
those proteins are shown in red there
and what they do is they bind the other
proteins on the outside of cells and
there's a number of different ways that
they do that I'm not going to go into in
any significant detail but we developed
a number of vaccines ECD ICD hlaa -
vaccine and what we call an e75 some of
these are still used today I've got a
slide that demonstrates that but what
these are doing is they're showing some
efficacy in blocking cancer development
one good example is from Brian's Ernie
Keyes lab at the University of
Pennsylvania and subsequently he has
moved to Moffitt Cancer Center in
Florida where he's shown that if he
gives vaccine to patients with very
early form of breast cancer DCIS then he
can get complete shrinkage of those
tumors with vaccination demonstrating
the power of the immune response so
we've had numerous vaccines that have
been tried for example against this
molecule her2/neu that have been
developed over the past ten to fifteen
years that are in clinical trials I'm
not going to talk about all of these
clinical trials I'm just going to give
you a couple of examples that are
demonstrating some promise and so for
example this is one graph that shows
that we can take these vaccines that
target these unique proteins P seven
seven six nine twenty seven and eleven
sixty-six and we can generate immune
responses by vaccinating individuals in
much the same way that you would be
vaccinated against the flu virus and
this in our animal models that develop
cancer shows protection that's shown in
those slides up there where you can give
tumors you can give excuse me mice
vaccines in these mice that develop
breast cancer can be protected from
developing breast cancer now we have
traditionally used vaccines to treat and
they haven't been
very effective rather vaccines should be
used for cancer in much the same way
that you would use a a cancer vaccine
for preventing disease and we prevent
disease we we use them to prevent
disease recurrence and individuals but
there are potentially new ways of
incorporating vaccines with a number of
other strategies that are being
developed and I'll talk briefly about
those here's a slide from a colleague of
mine at antigen Express which is a
company that I consult with from time to
time and they immunized with a vaccine
that we developed several years ago and
the patients that are above that red
line developed immune responses and the
patients that are below that red line
each shown as an individual symbol did
not develop immune responses now look at
those red dots in there those are the
patients that relapse so you can clearly
see in that cohort of people that
developed immune responses above that
red line there was very few relapses and
we're seeing this and this is one great
example of the use of vaccines to
prevent the redevelopment of cancer
after individuals have been treated with
normal conventional chemotherapy and
surgery so those were old strategies
they didn't work in everybody and so
over the last 10 years or so we've been
trying to develop vaccine strategies
that can be used off the shelf and
nearly everybody now I'm not going to go
into all of these different permutations
and and experimental designs that we use
but one of the things that we did is we
actually addressed in individuals how
well these individual vaccine components
worked in the culture dish and that's
kind of shown here and then we come up
with a score that enables us to pick
certain parts of proteins that we can
formulate into our vaccine in this
particular case we had 15 different
proteins and we formulated in for those
are emboldened in this particular table
because they had very high levels of
binding to immune recognition
culés in the body and we subsequently
have gone on to employ this vaccine in
individuals that have had her to new
positive breast cancer and you can
clearly see on this slide that we can
generates very potent immune responses
with vaccination in these individuals
but what's important and unlike the old
vaccines that we had developed were able
to generate immunity and the vast
majority of patients so that wasn't like
the old vaccines that I showed on
previous slides where we only saw maybe
40 maybe 30 percent of individuals
developing immune responses so we have
new and improved were ways so this was a
Phase one clinical trial and it enabled
us to determine whether or not the
vaccination process was safe in
individuals that were apparently cured
from their cancer but at high risk for
redevelopment of that cancer at some
point in the future now what's
interesting is that patients that are on
that have had breast cancer in a special
form called her2 new positive breast
cancer are given monoclonal antibody
trust who's a map or Herceptin as it's
called in the marketplace and what we
found in those individuals is that they
develop an internal or an endogenous
immune response against their cancer so
we're looking at ways to improve that
and what's shown here is a graph showing
increased immunity on the upper
left-hand side and on the two graphs on
the right-hand side we see what we call
kaplan-meier curves and those
individuals that develop immune
responses which is shown in the red line
have much improved survival compared to
those that don't so that's telling us
that we need to boost the immune system
in these individuals and in fact we just
received a grant from the Department of
Defense enabling us to test this vaccine
in patients with advanced or to new
positive breast cancer in what we call a
phase 2 clinical trial now these are
very expensive trials very complex to
run thus the grant was 11 million
dollars to do this and we have two arms
we have armed two and three one of those
arms the the ones with the green arrows
that group of patients are going to
receive vaccine we're going to compare
those with individuals in arm 2 which is
the yellowish orange arrows and
determine whether or not vaccine can
improve their immune system or immune
response to their cancer and whether or
not it can't protect against the
redevelopment of the subsets of her to
her breast cancer is called her2 new
positive breast cancer so we're working
on other strategies too for example
patients with triple negative breast
cancer a very rare form of breast cancer
are known to to develop immune responses
against this protein called fully
receptor alpha which is present on the
outside of the tumor cells I'm not going
to go into all of the data but we
clearly demonstrate in both ovarian and
breast cancer patients that we have high
levels of immunity that are generated
and we can try to understand that
immunity try to understand what's being
targeted and formulate that into
vaccines we conducted using that
approach in patients with ovarian and
breast cancer we developed the vaccines
that are as effective in these patients
as we saw with her2 new vaccines in her2
new positive breast cancer patients as
well that was just recently published in
clinical cancer research and in fact we
have numerous clinical trials both in
ovarian cancer and breast cancer in
which we're trying this vaccine and I'll
talk a little bit about the results in
just a few moments but needless to say
they're they're very effective in
generating immune responses and have the
potential to improve immune responses
against the cancer and protect
individuals and I'll talk a little bit
about what those trials are on a later
slide but this is just one example of a
Phase two clinical trial in patients
after they've been treated with
conventional therapy we're vaccinating
them for several months after and then
giving them boosters and we're
seeing efficacy in preventing now
there's opportunities also for combining
this with antibodies that are used for
the treatment of ovarian cancer so
there's one antibody called far Lechuza
mam which improves progression-free
survival and overall survival in
patients with a subset of patients with
ovarian cancer that are defined by this
marker ca-125 so those individuals have
improved progression-free survival
top-right graph and improve overall
survival bottom right graph and our hope
is that we can combine with these other
modalities to further improve immunity
in those individuals as well now those
are the approaches that were taking with
the non mutated antigens but recently I
although I told you it's not as easy
we've been starting to target mutations
that are that develop in individuals and
this is a personalized approach so we're
developing in collaboration with a
company called trans gene my back and so
each individual that participates in
these trials will be given a vaccination
that targets their own proteins that are
abnormal in those in their tumor cells
and so this is less off of the shelf
potentially very effective now what this
requires is the development of what we
call neo antigen discovery
bioinformatics pipelines so we take
individuals tubers and we run through
what we call bioinformatics pipelines to
identify specific antigens that are
unique to that patient and with all of
this power of computers and all of these
pipelines we think that we'll be able to
develop a tailor or tailored or
personalized vaccine for each individual
so those individuals that may not
benefit from some of the other vaccine
approaches we can actually now start
thinking about what we can look at in
their cancers in order to develop a
vaccine so that's going to be something
that we're going to be looking at in the
few
so I had talked about this idea that
immune suppression occurs in the ovarian
cancer microenvironment and breast
cancer micro environment and that blocks
anti-tumor immune responses so we're
thinking of developing vaccines that can
over power that immune system this is
particularly important in ovarian cancer
which has very profound immune
suppression in the micro environment and
if you do manage to boost immune
responses with a vaccine they still have
a hard time in the ovarian cancer micro
environment so we're looking at ways
that we can develop vaccines that
overpower that immune suppression so
what we've known is that in patients
with ovarian cancer they have high
levels of aisle 7 those that have high
levels of aisle 17 in their tumors have
much improved survival you can see here
on the kaplan-meier curve on the right
hands or the left hand side you can see
the light curve showing improved
survival in those individuals that have
high levels of aisle 17 and the reason
that they have improved levels improved
survival with aisle 17 it's that il-17
on the right hand graph is associated
with reduced immune suppression that's
called T regs and so the higher the
level of aisle 17 or th 17 is were
calling it in this slide the reduced
immune suppression that they have in
their tumor micro-environment so we've
actually developed a novel clinical
trial that we're testing right now in
patients following primary treatment in
which we've come up with a very
specialized vaccine that induces aisle
17 and they helps the body fight the
immune suppression the tumor
microenvironment now this on this aisle
17 inducing vaccine generates aisle 17
that's what we want that overcomes the
immune suppression that you were micro
environment so shown on the left hand of
the right slide is clearly evidence that
we can induce aisle 17 in the tumor
micro-environment
in patients
and using our sophisticated approaches
we're able to develop vaccines that
target the vast majority of individuals
with ovarian cancer using this vaccine
and so this shows who responds to which
antigens contained in the vaccine and
how many respond and as you can see a
high number of patients out of the 19 or
patients that we had immunized in this
particular trial demonstrate immune
responses following vaccination now
what's important is that we're out now
at about four years and what we're
finding what this particular vaccine
approaches that forty percent roughly of
ovarian cancer patients have not
relapsed over the course of four years
this is an older slide it shows up to 32
months but we've done now nearly four
years in this trial so I would have
expected and the literature would have
borne out this this recurrence rate of
approximately 90 to 95% so we look to be
protecting individuals and we're looking
at ways that we can improve recurrence
free survival in these individuals we
still continue to use innovative
approaches to identify novel antigens or
proteins in the tumor microenvironment
now what we know is that the tumor
consists of what we call cancer stem
cells and these are what gives rise to
new tumors they're very flexible so they
can either cause a dark blue purplish
blue tumor which is shown here in this
diagram or they can produce a green
tumor and if your immunizing against the
great in green tumor you may not be able
to combat the purplish blue tumor so
we're looking at ways that we can
identify new antigens that are present
on these stem cells and the reason that
that's important that that are the
evidence that we have that that's
important is we see now in patients that
depending on the site that is immuno
genic in individuals we see different
types of tumors so the tumors look
different depending on where they're at
in the body and that's due
these stem cells so you can see here in
this diagram here that liver and spleen
have a certain form of tumor cells
whereas the primary tumor cells are
those that are associated with other
organs or tissues in the body have a
different phenotype or a different
appearance to the immune system so our
vaccine strategies may not be complete
and then we'll need additional antigens
in order to prevent recurrence at
specific sites very complicated but
nonetheless something that we continue
to study this is just a great example on
this line that we have developed
vaccines that target not only the tumor
cells but also the cancer stem cells on
the left hand side there shows that we
can generate immune responses to cancer
stem cell antigens but most importantly
we can immunize in just three times mice
with very aggressive tumors and as long
as we target the cancer stem cell we can
get regression of the tumor now if we
stop vaccinating the tumors will
ultimately grow out we're continuing to
look at ways to prevent cancers from
growing out in those individuals by
targeting their cancer stem cells so all
of the strategies that I talked about we
think are going to be most useful in
vaccines that prevent the redevelopment
of breast or ovarian cancers now that's
the best approach if you think about the
flu virus if you think about the measles
virus if you think about the polio virus
we don't use those vaccines to treat
individuals we use them to prevent
disease that's where we think so I think
over the next four or five years we'll
start to get in data about vaccines that
can prevent diseases from coming back
and that's going to be particularly
useful and that way patients can have
their immune system stimulated after
conventional therapy to prevent the
disease from coming back because when it
comes back it tends to be very
aggressive or it gets into sites in the
body which you're really hard to get to
for example in the skeleton
or in the liver or in the brain and
that's how they end up dying as a result
of these distant metastases so I had
talked briefly about immune checkpoint
blockade when I was referring to
President Jimmy Carter and the success
that he had as well as a success of
under other individuals that have been
treated with these kinds of strategies
an immune checkpoint blockade is an
approach that uses antibodies these
y-shaped things that are shown toward
the middle on each the right on the left
can block immune regulatory interactions
in the tumor microenvironment so you can
see there on the left there's this Y
shaped antibody called anti pd-1 and it
blocks the interaction between PD 1 and
PDL 1 now that's not useful in all
people in fact it's not useful in the
vast majority of people but we do know
that some people respond at very the
respond very nicely in some cases with
complete shrinkage of the tumors so in
those particular patients those
individuals have tend to have very high
levels of already existing immune
responses now in ovarian cancer we see
very limited activity in these immune
checkpoint mob blockade molecules in
ovarian cancer much less than we see in
malignant melanoma or non-small-cell
lung cancer so for example in this
particular study there was two complete
responses out of all of the several
patients that were treated in this
clinical trial and what we have have and
others have observed is that the
patients that don't respond don't have
t-cells so what happens or what would
what would happen if we combined a
immune checkpoint blockade molecules
such as anti PD 1 or anti PDL one with
vaccines to boost those immune responses
and this is exactly what we did in this
mouse model of breast cancer in which we
knives mice with a vaccine and then we
gave them anti pd-1 and I showed you on
the previous slide that these animals
can actually undergo regression of the
tumors but it grows out what we observed
is that we combine vaccine with immune
checkpoint blockade we have 75 percent
complete regression rate in these
animals and some ultimately redevelop
cancer and don't survive as a result but
this is extending the life of these mice
from on the order of 25 or 30 days with
breast cancer to over a hundred and
fifty days or a half-year so we think
that this is an approach that we could
potentially use in the clinic to treat
patients that have active malignancy so
this is different than the setting of
preventing recurrence in individuals but
rather giving them a vaccine and
overriding the regulatory mechanisms in
the tumor micro-environment with immune
checkpoint blockade leading to improve
survival and this is borne out in their
new responses as well so this example
slide shows that patients that are
treated with both immune checkpoint
blockade and vaccine develop higher
levels of t-cells that's shown in the
far far right-hand parts of the bars and
the graphs there where you show very
high levels of immune responses of
flavors which shown in the pie graph
that are associated with improved
survival so all in all our strategy has
to defend and develop vaccines for
breast and ovarian cancer we have
several approaches that are ongoing so
we have folate receptor or fr vaccines
to be combined with anti PDL one those
trials are ongoing now we have
standalone vaccines such as FRDC vaccine
triple negative breast cancer fr vaccine
a ovarian cancer fr vaccine and then we
have her two new vaccines which are
being used to prevent disease
recurrence in individuals we're also
very much interested in the development
of vaccines for primary prevention of
cancer and so in the last couple of
slides I earned this last slide here I
just want to talk about our efforts to
develop a vaccine so with the national
breast cancer coalition we've come up
with a strategy that we've developed
over the past few years which is shown
or the mission is shown in the blue box
which is kind of discombobulated due to
some problems with the with the
transmission of the slides but
nonetheless the strategy or the mission
of this interaction with national breast
cancer coalition is to develop a vaccine
that targets all of the three major
subsets of breast cancer to develop a
vaccine that reduces the incidence of
breast cancer and one that prevents
death from breast cancer and that is
safe and cost effective so in much the
same way that you would be given a
vaccine for the prevention of cervical
cancer by targeting the the human
papilloma virus we want to develop a key
a vaccine that prevents development of
breast cancer we have to target these
abnormal self proteins because we don't
have viruses that cause breast cancer
and so over the past couple of years
we've refined our understanding of what
we need to incorporate in that vaccine
and to specifically develop a vaccine
that blocks all three major forms of
breast cancer so we have have made this
vaccine that targets her2 new Mei j-3
maquon survived and mammon globin a and
H dirt which all bind or which all are
expressed in the breast cancer micro
environment and could be potential
targets for vaccines and this in
collaboration with the national breast
cancer coalition is just getting
underway it's been approved to a certain
extent by the FDA for testing in humans
we're still on the pathway to using it
as a primary
prevention for breast cancer but
hopefully with the development of this
vaccine and potentially other vaccines
for breast cancer we're going to be able
to reduce the burden on society that
held that ovarian cancer and breast
cancers represent by reducing the
incidence of the diseases and when you
reduce the incidence of the diseases you
reduce the need for treatment you reduce
the lost productivity due to death or
due to having to go to the doctors or
spending time in the hospital etc we
really want to save lives and we want to
really reduce the amount of resources
that are going to protection against
breast cancer and ovarian cancer which I
showed way back in the first slide
represents a significant fraction of our
gross domestic product so our approach
has been in general to develop vaccines
that we can give either to prevent
cancer or to prevent the redevelopment
of cancer this is how cancer vaccines
should be used this is a change people
have wanted to use vaccines for
treatment but they don't work for
treatment we need more effective
clinical settings so in this particular
case this is showing a graph of a
patient hoard that has had ovarian
cancer after we treat them their tumor
volume goes down of course with surgery
and chemotherapy
we have windows of opportunity that we
can continue to boost the immune
response shown in the green line there
and we can do that with vaccines so more
needs to be done in this disease-free
period let's not wait and see if the
cancer comes back
let's give individuals with vaccine
booster immune response maintain that
immunity in order to prevent disease
from coming back so we're learning that
new ways to develop these vaccines as I
already talked about particularly
identifying the aberrantly Express
proteins
and hopefully formulating those into
effective approaches that prevent
recurrence we're also learning ways that
the immune system is blocking the
t-cells and b-cells in the micro
environment so we're working on ways of
what we call depolarizing immune
responses making them a multitude of
different flavors that could potentially
work in concert together to eradicate
the cancer we're also thinking about
combining with antibody therapy antibody
therapy also induces in the in responses
can we combine for example Herceptin
plus vaccine in patients that are at
high risk for redevelopment of her2 new
breast cancer or ovarian cancer or
similar cancers by combining vaccine
with monoclonal antibodies there are
also some potential opportunities in the
future for employing vaccines for the
treatment of individuals with bulky
malignancy but that's not going to be
with vaccines alone we think that's
going to be with the Muench at point
blockade immune checkpoint blockade
doesn't work in the vast majority of
individuals because they lack that
immune response we're going to give them
that immune response by him immunizing
them and treating them with an immune
checkpoint blockade clinical trials are
underway to test how do we do that in
patients with actively growing disease
one of the things that we need to do
though is continue to study individuals
for a new escape so some of these
approaches they may seem quite effective
but the tumors will grow out and so some
of the strategies that we're looking at
as we move forward in cancer vaccine
development is trying to understand what
new mechanisms the immune or the tumors
turn on in order to evade the immune
response I didn't talk about that today
but there's a number of strategies that
are being developed so all in all our
approach has been to use vaccines
appropriately either in disease
prevention or in combination
with the immune checkpoint blockade or
other types of antibody approaches we've
been very well funded by the Department
of Defense for several tens of millions
of dollars the National Institutes of
Health particularly the National Cancer
Institute and we've got a great team at
Mayo I'm not going to go into all of
these names but it really takes a good
collaborative team throughout the Mayo
Clinic Enterprise as well as individuals
outside of Mayo that have come together
to support the development of approaches
that we think are going to be in fact
effective at reducing the risk of death
from breast cancer and ovarian cancer
and I thank you very much for your
attention today
thank you dr. cannerts in for that
informative presentation we will now
start the Q&A portion of the webinar and
we'll address some of the most commonly
asked questions by our viewers if you
have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question drop-down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
type your question into the box it
appears on your screen and click the
send button our speaker will follow up
with your questions via email let's get
started our first question is how are
cancer vaccines different than ordinary
infectious disease vaccines right that's
that's a really great question so just
to put it very simply they are different
in in some ways but the same in other
ways so vaccines are designed to boost
these T cells and these B cells in the
body those are very unique so when we
use a polio vaccine or an influenza
vaccine or measles vaccine or a tetanus
those are targeting something or
proteins that come from the infectious
agent so and they block viral entry and
they cause disease
if
if there's nothing there to stop them so
we're targeting with infectious disease
vaccines were targeting microbes
bacteria or viruses with infections or
excuse me with cancer vaccines in
contrast we don't have the same
opportunities for targeting microbes and
so we need to go into the cancers and
figure out what's different in the
cancers so we can identify proteins
which are not derived from microbes that
we can stimulate immune responses
against and so there while the concept
of vaccination to stimulate those
t-cells to stimulate those b-cells is
much the same the targets that we are
choosing for our vaccine are different
which chart were typically targeting
proteins that are present normally in
the body but are deranged in some way by
the cancer that the immune system can
see whereas with infectious disease
vaccines just to reiterate we're
actually targeting proteins that are
produced by the bacteria or the
infectious agent but are not normally
part of the body
thank you very interesting next one is
in what clinical cancer setting are
vaccines most likely to be effective
when used alone yeah so as I had
mentioned the the use of vaccines has
never been to treat disease we think
about influenza every year and many of
us get the flu and many of us get other
types of illnesses that can be prevented
with vaccines but not once if you have
the flu does the doctor offer you a flu
vaccine and the reason is is because by
that time it's too late and the flu has
already started to block the immune
system and in order to run its course
now with flu it runs its course for only
a
period of time it doesn't want to kill
its host and so it's adaptive ways to
you know make most of us sick it does
kill certain individuals particularly
the old that don't have immune systems
but the you know the the strategy is
that you you boost the immune systems so
that and the patient has immunity prior
to getting the disease and so in the in
cancer it's after we've eliminated the
disease with surgery with chemotherapy
then we boost the immune response and
when the tumors start to come back your
immune system remains heightened just
like it does after you get a flu vaccine
such that it can respond very rapidly
and overcome all of these immune
suppressive mechanisms and so the
clinical setting is to prevent disease
not to treat disease thank you for that
looks like we have time for one more
question if the immune system naturally
sees cancer why do they continue to grow
yeah so there's a number of different
strategies that they continue to grow
despite the fact that the immune system
they and and I briefly alluded to this
in the presentation that they develop
all these immune regulatory networks
that suppress the immune response so
your immune system is one of the most
powerful organs so to speak in your body
it can attack specific tissues very
specifically and over a very short
period of time and completely destroy
that tissue so somebody that has had a
transplant if you don't suppress their
immune system they can completely
eliminate that transplanted lung or that
transplanted heart or whatever tissue is
transplanted and they can it can happen
against cancer too but the reason that
cancers do grow out is because there are
a wide variety of immune suppressant
molecules normal
found in the immune system it's very
tightly controlled and different tissues
in your body use these mechanisms to
prevent the immune system from attacking
it now the thing about cancer is it uses
all of these mechanisms to block the
immune response and so this is very
critical because there's a number of
different immune suppressive mechanisms
so when we try to understand a patient's
cancer we try to understand what immune
suppressive mechanisms that that cancer
is using and even if we do apply
something that can be effective at
stimulating the immune system and
overcoming the cancer the immune system
can can excuse-me the tumor can actually
turn on a new immune suppressive
mechanism and so the ability of tumors
to go through all of these immune
suppressive mechanisms that we have in
our body in order to find the right ones
to evade the immune system is what
happens when cancers grow out thank you
I would like to once again thank dr.
Knudsen for his presentation would also
like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through January
11th 2019 you'll receive an email from
lab roots letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
event that's all for now thank you for
joining us we hope to see you again soon
goodbye